este domingo harquip arrancó el día con
bombardeos en mitad de la mañana un
misil Ruso alcanzó un edificio
Residencial y otro la universidad de
economía de la ciudad dejando varios
heridos
por casualidad acabamos de entrar al
baño y ocurrió justo después de entrar
mi marido quedó completamente cubierto
de cristales pero todo el mundo está
vivo eso es lo importante Dios nos ama
[Aplausos]
mientras en Ciudad crucial de los
frentes a más sangrientos de la guerra
los combates continúan
con varios civiles muertos este domingo
las fuerzas ucranianas siguen intentando
contrarrestar a los rusos
en los barrios del norte de artemox se
están librando feroces batallas por cada
calle cada casa cada escalera además en
el terreno la guerra entre Rusia y
Ucrania también se libra con discursos
cruzados el Ministerio de defensa ruso
acusó a Ucrania de preparar ataques a
edificios de civiles en clamatoros para
después culpar a Moscú de crímenes de
guerra la fiscalía de Alemania ya ha
asegurado tener pruebas de miles de
estos supuestos crímenes rusos en este
punto del conflicto Ucrania está a la
espera de recibir tanques y armamento de
occidente aunque sea comprometido a no
disparar Estas armas en suelo ruso para
no escalar la guerra
hemos dicho oficialmente a nuestros
aliados que no usaremos las armas
proporcionadas para disparar en
territorio ruso solo disparamos contra
las unidades rusas en el territorio
ucraniano temporalmente ocupado para
liberar nuestras tierras
quién cree que Rusia podría estar
planeando una ofensiva para este mes
como más simbólico que estratégico por
el aniversario de la invasión y el
ministro aseguró que están preparados
para poder defenderse